traveling through the electoral
battleground it's becoming obvious that
history offers no clear guide to likely
winners and losers the forum book has
been torn up places where the main
Westminster parties held sway are under
siege seats that were safe as houses
look margin great Grimsby labor labor
since the war
I've always been labor and I'll never
change but that sort of enthusiasm is
dwindling here much of a fire of
politics only if anyone's going to shoot
them as you'd expect a town like Grimsby
that's lived off it stops and it's
fishing port has proud labor roots the
real worry for Ed Miliband and it's not
just here is that some voters now feel
the party has abandoned its traditional
values which party would you say
represents working people at the moment
you kick off a UK person like that
Labour know where the 30 or not they're
trying to pay more for the sort of
floating voters I think they'd forgotten
about the working-class people to fill
urine a minority as a Lib Dem in Grimsby
yes
people whose candidates don't have a
shot at winning may change horses
tactical voting looks like being a big
deal in May 2015
here's how the Grimsby picture is
changing last time around you could vote
for labour or the Tories and you had a
good chance of winning the Lib Dems did
fine too
now though we have up-to-date
constituency polling which shows the Lib
Dems falling off a cliff
the Conservatives going backwards to so
many voters may conclude it's a straight
fight a straight choice between labour
and UK how things change in 2010 David
Cameron smelt an outside chance of a
conservative win here and campaigned
within hours of polling day now his
candidate has jumped ship to you Kip for
the Tories this looks like one that got
away
so food-for-thought across the board
from seats like Grimsby back to the
center old assumptions are being shaken